hi I'm just going to talk about this
question that's categorized under
technology I'm just going to read it
unemployment rates are rising and one of
the main reason is because technology is
replacing labor how can we solve the
unemployment crisis and improve the
standards of living workers when there
is rapid growth in technology use okay
well I wanted to talk about this because
I sort of agree with this and I sort of
don't I mean obviously this question was
sent by someone in a developed country
because really if you look at the impact
of technology on balance it definitely
is creating jobs but it is not
necessarily creating jobs where jobs
have historically existed so you know
the single biggest impact of technology
is to bring the world together to allow
more collaboration to allow what we call
in business and value chains to emerge
that it connects different players in a
variety of different parts of the world
eat or in a city but increasingly it's
convenient and more affordable for a
company to have some kind of work done
in a region where the people will work
for less and that isn't comfortable for
the people who might have otherwise done
the job in a higher wage region but for
those people who get the job in the
region where they are willing to work
for less the reason they're willing to
work for less is because there no other
jobs there so if you take a global view
I think you can argue that technology is
an unalloyed benefit to employment and
and the other way I think technology is
a benefit to employment and I'll get in
a minute to how I agreed it with this
question is that it's basically just
increasing the pace of the economy and
when economic payson and economic
activity speeds up that tends to create
more value
and more productivity and more jobs
almost by definition and I am very much
a believer as a technology writer I
wrote a book about Facebook called the
Facebook effect and I've written about
technology for 20 years that technology
is increasing the pace of communication
and therefore making a lot of things
more efficient in modern society
efficiency leads to productivity overall
leads to jobs again those jobs may not
be in the developed world but let me
just like so but there isn't a
legitimate question if the developed
world is where we live which I do I live
in New York how are you going to get
more jobs especially for people with
less training in an age when technology
is having all these effects and I think
we don't have the answer especially in a
country like the US where education is
so disregarded so the only real answer
to unemployment caused by technology
which really is more about displacing
jobs than actually making them
unnecessary is better education so that
people can do higher value work because
if the pace of the economy increases
there's always going to be work for
people who are trained that's my overall
view on that so thanks a lot